[Music]
hello and welcome back to our Friday
face off challenge with well who isn't
me very you the contribution beauty
editor and I wonder what entertainment
editor Josh Smith hi
so we are going to be replicating a look
that we don't know what the look is just
yet I'm going to be revealed to us in a
moment and we're gonna have to do that
look in five minutes I want to know how
good you are before I accept this
challenge
that's II think is the best outcome is
it odd check that out
oh she's juicy isn't she it's seriously
chasing like a vase juicy orange lips
and the neon eye
I'm really liking these eyes because
they're kind of like a sunrise effect I
feel like I might be able to do that how
you feel I don't well I want to say
positive ish let's hope it in it like
clones have very light eyebrows so I'm
drawing them on it's gonna be tricky bar
ready for that's too good that's gay
game on you're going downtown baby go
okay time sauces oh okay I think so good
that you don't I think I know you're
talking about right I'm going in going
in with a little bit of you oh my god
what am i done i licked the bus with my
dog
no never do that bacteria how many eyes
be done to hop ice I'm on the hook right
you're on units already yeah I don't
know what this is what is this this
product does what is this you're on your
lips are you know I'm on my cheek do you
look anything like her she needs to be
taxed into a knee okay right I look a
little bit like I've got conjunctivitis
two minutes left oh my lips do not let
you see
I can't wait to see I've literally
ruined it no I need I just tried to do a
freckle situation I've got really prick
teats
oh my god babe I've got a massive
problem
look I'm cheating a little bit blend
blend
oh my god oh this couldn't be anyone no
oh my god this is so unfair
this is unfair because you do this every
single bloody day and I let you do this
I feel like I'm glowing so much you can
see me through space this is when yours
is really good where would you wear this
G where you going to this look we're all
starting guys I will never get a feller
if I look like this we've bent angered
we have believed in time guys
I don't even you right let's see Dave
return no I think okay in terms of
skills maybe slightly I guess I've got
the sunrise I don't know but sure when
you try to get it
I got a sunrise sunset and the sun
exposure I know I really came here
thanks so much for watching remember to
Like subscribe and comment because we
will know who's won so even vote for
Becky or vote for me and during this
next Friday for another Friday face up
and don't get to use the hashtag hashtag
guess what it is
probably faces and don't forget for more
videos like this you can subscribe to
the glamour UK channel so make sure you
do it right now you've done it
Yeah right absolutely anyways if you
want to go out with someone who looks
this orange and is in general in touch
don't touch
glamour that's why you'll find them